hmm this is what it's like waiting for
the Samsung Galaxy Nexus to release on
Verizon you know it's coming you can see
it already you can practically smell it
it is just so close you can probably
already see other people have it but
it's just not here yet come on see the
Samsung Galaxy Nexus is not just any
other new Android phone Nexus devices
are always the reference device for what
Google built this new OS on so it's
basically Android 4.0 built for this
phone you can watch my video that I
already put up on that right here there
are so many great things about the
already released international unlock
version of this phone I keep telling
myself sometimes I really wonder what's
going on behind the scenes with Verizon
hey important guy with a clipboard do
you think that we should release the
Galaxy Nexus today I think maybe we
should announce it or something like
seriously Verizon December 9th is the
last straw when Google presented this
phone two months ago they promised not
to steal carriers thunder but they
basically told people that this device
would be released sometime by the end of
the year but Verizon really needs to say
something I don't care if this device is
released December 31st
but if Verizon doesn't actually tell
anyone about it this goes down as the
worst product launch I have ever seen
thumbs up if you agree with that I
realized that there are slight
modifications that they need to make
from the international version like the
slightly thicker body slightly larger
battery and the LTE radio inside I get
that but Verizon please don't get
carried away we know you like your Droid
brand and you like to make it a Verizon
device but this is also a Nexus device
we've seen leaked shots of the Nexus
that's supposed to come to Verizon and I
can't even find any Google branding on
it I mean this is supposed to be a
Google flagship device not necessarily a
Verizon flagship note I mean you know to
me I don't know maybe I'm missing
something but if you agree with me
maybe you can share this video and maybe
we can try to get Verizon to actually
say something again I really hope
December 9th is the date the date
I hopefully will be doing lots of videos
on it when I finally get the phone
either way thanks for watching this
video guys and mkbhd signing out